[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
and it looks like the jokes on you if if
you were one of the people that
didn't like charadelio's joker i guess
which let's let's be honest it wasn't
many
as he's coming back to reprise his role
as the clown prince of crime
in zack snyder's justice league we're
going to be getting into the whole story
in this video but if you haven't
subscribed to this channel for whatever
reason yeah
what the hell are you doing with your
life make make sure you do
now according to the hollywood reporter
jared leto
is confirmed to be coming back as the
joker and he's going to be shooting some
additional scenes for zack snyder's
justice league
in which he sort of gets the chance to
do what he really wanted to
now if you were following the story of
suicide squad you might remember that
behind the scenes there was a lot of
talk about
how groundbreaking his performance was
going to be how annoying it was for the
other actors
and it was meant to be something really
really special
however that seems to have got left on
the cutting room floor
and lito was very annoyed at how his
performance came across
personally i really didn't like the
actor in the movie and
i just didn't think that it fully
delivered on the promise that
that i was expecting from joker you have
to remember that this came just after
heath ledger's joker
and therefore to have this weird
gangster with tattoos and golden teeth
it was a bit of a disappointment both
joaquin phoenix and heath ledger won
oscars for their portrayal of the joker
and yeah it's always kind of a sour note
that lito
never really got the chance to do what
he wanted to however this seems to be
his chance of redemption
and he has officially joined reshoots
for zack snyder's justice league
according to the hollywood reporter the
project officially titled
zack snyder's justice league is being
overseen by hbo max
which is financing the new round of
shooting and the completion of many
unfinished scenes
and will air as a four episode event
series next year
shooting is currently underway with ben
affleck ray fisher
and amber heard boo and of course jared
leto
now it's unclear which other actors are
involved but we can expect quite a lot
from this release
and it really seems like they're trying
to fix everything that was wrong with
the joss whedon version of the film
which let's face it that was two two
hours of
completely wrong stuff now there's also
a lot of controversy behind the scenes
as both
john berg and jeff johns you know ray
fishes said some things about them
recently and
it's not painted them out in a good
light so i'm guessing that hbo max are
really trying to get as much goodwill
behind the project as they can
and thus they're bringing lito back now
it's a really weird time to be a comic
book movie fan as
at the moment it just seems like they're
bringing back pretty much everyone out
the woodwork
and yeah last week it was like jamie
foxx's electro
and this week it's charlie o's joker
kind of hoping that george clooney's
batman returns at some point
and maybe uh it would be ice to see mr
frieza you're having that
anyway we don't know what scenes these
are gonna be and
i pretty much had a full breakdown of
what the original shooting schedule of
zack snyder's script was
and it seems like this is all additional
footage that wasn't originally planned
in the in the intended version basically
i'm kind of hoping that we get that face
off between deathstroke and batman
that face-off between batman and joker
and
yeah this is just ticking all the boxes
for me right now as i said leo wasn't my
preferred version of the character
but it would be great to see you know
him finally get the chance to redeem
himself now obviously i'd love to hear
your thoughts on the story
so make sure you comment below and let
me know if you enjoy this video and want
something else to watch
then check out our breakdown of
everything we know about spider-man 3
which is gonna be linked at the end
don't forget we're also giving away
three copies of the marvel phase one box
set
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe to the channel and
drop a comment below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of october and the set will
be shipped out from then to ever gets
the prize
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content like this early then
please consider clicking the join button
below
it's only 99 cents and you get access to
a lot of stuff
anyway thank you for sticking until the
end of the video i've been definition
you've been the worst haha and i'll see
you next time the jokes on you you
sucker
bye
you